[Musique]
de la Chine parce que c'est vraiment pas
tous les jours qu'on entend la Chine
faire les loges du multilatéralisme
surtout sur un sujet où elle semble
d'accord avec les États-Unis les
intentions semblent bonnes à la cop27
qui se poursuit en Égypte mais
donneront-elles des résultats concrets
on sent l'urgence partout dans le monde
allez on se pose la question de son côté
le gouvernement canadien est représenté
par son ministre de l'Environnement
Steven Guilbaud il est un habitué de ses
grands rendez-vous internationaux c'est
son 20e en fait alors je lui ai parlé en
fin d'après-midi
vous êtes Chanel chic en Egypte cop27
attire l'attention de grand leader à
travers le monde vous représenter le
Canada comment avez-vous réagi à la
déclaration d'Antonio guterrese qui
existe un pacte de suicide ou un pack
pour la solidarité est-ce que ça définit
bien la situation à laquelle on est
confronté
évidemment la situation on le sait elle
est très précaire les impacts des
changements climatiques se produisent de
plus en plus et avec et avec de plus en
plus forte alors c'est un fait on
constate au Canada mais on constate bien
entendu à l'échelle planétaire en même
temps il y a une controverse ici quand
qui est soulevé une simple fait que vous
avez invité au Pavillon du Canada que
vous avez je pense lancez aujourd'hui là
les pétrolières les pétrolières qui sont
en cause dans la lutte contre le
changement climatiques est-ce qu'un test
de crédibilité ici que vous devez passer
là-dessus
je pense que si on éliminait les
secteurs d'activité qui contribuent au
changement climatique on invite à
personne nous contribuons toutes et tous
tous les secteurs d'activité que ce soit
l'agriculture la production
d'électricité le transport les bâtiments
le contrat que nous avons pris le contre
moral avec les Canadiens les Canadiens
dans la lutte au changement climatique
c'est que nous avions travaillé avec
toutes les régions du pays et tous les
secteurs d'activités pour relever le
défi des changements climatiques on peut
pas dire bon ben ce secteur là on l'aime
pas donc on va pas lui parler on va on
va l'ignorer
c'est pas sérieux et d'ailleurs
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
logique reconnaît ce que nous allons
encore utiliser du pétrole en 2050 dans
un monde carbone neutre nous allons en
utiliser beaucoup moins qu'aujourd'hui
mais il va en rester alors cette idée-là
que le pétrole va disparaître du
portefeuille énergétique c'est pas ce
que les experts nous disent le danger
aux yeux de certains c'est que ces
pétrolières font de l'écho blanchement
en fait de ce qu'on vient dans le
greenwashing sont là pour se faire une
réhabilitée la réputation et qu'en
réalité ça va être difficile d'atteindre
les résultats rechercher pour lutter
contre les changements climatiques
Anne-Marie ça va être difficile
d'atteindre des résultats dans tous les
secteurs et c'est difficile pour tous
les pays moi je rencontre je rencontre
des délégués de l'Europe du Japon des
États-Unis même des pays scandinaves il
y a personne qui me dit chez nous là
réduire les émissions gaz à effet de
serre là on fait sans boire sans les
dents le matin c'est un défi pour tout
le monde dans tous les secteurs mais on
peut pas laisser ça au volontariat c'est
pourquoi nous avons nous sommes battu
jusqu'à en cours suprême pour pouvoir
mettre en place une tarification carbone
c'est pourquoi nous mettons en place des
des règlements sur plafonner les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre du
secteur du pétrole du gaz réduire les
émissions de méthane et comme je l'ai
fait la semaine dernière de en fait
comme nous l'avons fait dans l'énoncé
économique on va imposer par exemple une
surtaxe dans pour les rachats d'actions
pour pour ces entreprises là donc pour
les forcer investir ces entreprises là
dans la décarbonisation
de leur industrie il en vade de leur
survie mais aussi des employés de
travailleurs de ces entreprises là et
des régions du Canada qui dépendent de
ça également le directeur parlementaire
du budget estime que ça coûte
extrêmement cher les effets des
changements climatiques donc ça implique
des milliards de dollars
comment faire face à la situation ici et
ailleurs dans le monde parce que comme
leader avec l'Allemagne vous avez mis au
point un programme 100 milliards de
dollars par année pour aider à faire
face aux changements climatiques dans
les pays les plus vulnérables mais on
estime que ça prendrait des milliers de
milliards de dollars est-ce que la cause
est perdue
non la cause elle n'est pas perdue bon
comment faire face d'abord nous allons
au cours des des prochains mois dévoiler
la stratégie nationale sur l'adaptation
au Canada c'est une ce sera la première
fois que nous faisons ça le fédéral a
des gens investi près de 4 milliards de
dollars dans l'adaptation donc comment
mieux se préparer aux impacts des
changements climatiques
et il faut faire ça à l'échelle interne
internationale aussi vous avez raison
100 milliards ce n'est que le début à
l'échelle internationale il y a beaucoup
de choses qu'on peut faire on peut faire
comme le Canada va faire d'ici l'an
prochain éliminer les subventions
combustibles fossiles à l'échelle
mondiale c'est 700 milliards de dollars
année après année que nous investissons
collectivement encore pour pour
augmenter la production de combustible
fossiles alors si comme nous on le fait
au Canada et on va le faire deux ans
plus tôt que nos partenaires du G20 si
on élimine ces subventions là et qu'on
redirige
c'est plus de capitaux là vers la lutte
au changement climatique vers
l'adaptation mais là c'est pas 100
milliards que nous aurons rapidement
mais c'est des centaines de milliards ce
qui est important aussi c'est la
participation du secteur privé les
gouvernements n'ont pas assez d'argent
pour faire face aux montants qui devront
être investir on parle de d'au moins
1000 milliards de dollars par année
d'ici 2030 à l'échelle planétaire donc
le secteur privé 1 euro l'important à
jouer également une précision pour les
subventions fossiles au Canada on va
continuer de subventionner ces
pétrolières-là pour certaines activités
non il y a pour la transition on a
subventionnera plus la production de
pétrole de gaz ou de charbon on va
souvent soigner la décarbonisation comme
on subventionne la décharmonisation du
secteur du ciment ou le secteur
d'aluminium au Québec ou le secteur de
l'automobile on va donc on va travailler
mais ça ne sera pas ce ne sera pas des
subventions et c'était l'engagement du
G20 d'éliminer les subventions pour la
production de combustible fossiles et
c'est souvent sur le il n'y en aura plus
au Canada d'ici l'an prochain deux
éléments avant de vous laisser c'est que
dans la foulée de la Coop vous voulez
aider donc les pays en matière de
justice climatique aidez les pays les
plus vulnérables mais cela veulent aussi
que vous payez pour les dommages causés
pas seulement aider les pays à s'adapter
mais payer pour les milliards milliards
de dollars que coûte les effets qu'on a
vu encore récemment Pakistan c'est le
tiers du pays qui est passé sous l'eau
est-ce que est-ce que les pays riches
vont aller jusque là
je pense que cette conversation là va
débuter ici à Sharm el chic et le Canada
supporte cette conversation il faut que
il faut qu'on discute de ça et qu'on
comprenne quels sont les besoins parce
que présentement on ne connaît pas les
besoins quels sont les mécanismes qui
existent au niveau international alors
il y a la Convention de l'ONU sur les
changements climatiques mais il y a
d'autres mécanismes de l'ONU il y a
d'autres institutions qui peuvent aider
au niveau international on pense aux
institutions multilatérales comme la
Banque mondiale le Fond Monétaire
International donc les gouvernements ont
un rôle à jouer là-dedans et je pense
qu'il faut commencer à voir cette
conversation là mais c'est pas juste les
gouvernements qui vont devoir
s'impliquer d'un point de vue financier
il va falloir que l'ensemble de la
collectivité mondiale s'y mettent parce
que sinon on y arrivera pas et de vos
solutions bien sûr c'est la taxe sur le
carbone qui va continuer d'augmenter
mais le débat politique si vous êtes un
gouvernement minoritaire un des débats
importants puis même l'Alberta le fait
c'est il est conservateurs le font c'est
justement d'éliminer la taxe sur le
carbone
est-ce que ça pourrait vous faire
reculer là dessus
non il n'est pas question je suis sidéré
par la potion du gouvernement
conservateur du Parti conservateur
fédéral et certains gouvernements
conservateurs promotions qui voudraient
que la pollution soit gratuite au Canada
6 c'est ridicule le système de prix sur
la pollution du Canada et si tu es en
exemple partout dans le monde comme
étant l'un des meilleurs l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie le fond on
était internationale dit si tout le
monde fait ce que c'est les plus grands
pollueurs de la planète faisait ce que
le Canada fait on serait déjà au tiers
de de l'atteindre de l'objectif de Paris
et et
pendant ce temps de conservateur du
Canada qui dit non non il faut que la
pollution soit gratuite c'est
sincèrement c'est
pourtant quand même un mec qui constate
que le Canada et ne pas atteindre ses
objectifs jusqu'à maintenant que les
émissions ont augmenté même dans le
documentaire dans le document du budget
on est dans des plus grands polluants
aussi
dont on parle nous sommes le quatrième
plus grand producteur de pétrole et gaz
au monde alors on va pas changer ça du
jour au lendemain nos émissions ont
diminué en 2019 et en 2020 c'est la
dernière année pour laquelle on a des
avantages donc le portrait commun ça
s'améliorer mais il faut réaliser que
nous changeons l'économie la structure
économique d'un pays de 38 millions
d'habitants ça se fera pas en deux ans
ça se reprend 5 ans ça sera pas en
disant on va être encore en train de
parler de ça dans 15 ans dans 25 ans
mais il faut commencer quelque part et
ce quelque part là c'est maintenant très
bien merci beaucoup Céline Guilbaud
depuis Charles bonne suite de cette
cop27 merci
justement la COP 27 se poursuit encore
jusqu'au 18 novembre le ministre
Guilbaud sera un de nos invités ce lundi
pour une édition spéciale de deux heures
de 24-60 le monde en manque en mal
d'énergie nous dresserons l'état de
situation de la crise énergétique
comment s'en sortir parce qu'il faut
trouver des solutions pour accélérer
aussi la transition énergétique alors un
rendez-vous lundi 14 novembre de 19h le
monde en mal d'énergie
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI